à cette guerre en ukraine amine loupe
sur un phénomène récurrent en temps de
conflit celui des violences sexuelles
des viols utilisés régulièrement comme
arme de guerre on en parle avec notre
invité céline bardet bon vous êtes
juriste
spécialiste justement en des questions
de crimes de guerre et fondatrice de
l'one de lohengrin hot wheels au noir
alors d'abord est-ce qu'on peut revenir
d'abord sur ce qui s'est passé à abuja
un c'est là que l'horreur a frappé
dernièrement ou après le passage des
soldats russes des corps de femme sans
vie ont été retrouvés jambes écartées
parfois avec des emballages déchiré de
préservatifs retrouvé non loin de leur
corps est ce que tous ces éléments qui
ont été trouvés ces dernières semaines
sont des preuves suffisantes pour
travailler sur ces viols qui sont
utilisées donc comme d'un comme des
armes de guerre
alors évidemment ce sont des preuves
suffisantes c'est une autre question
mais je pense que celles ci elles sont
quand même extrêmement explicite et
qu'elles peuvent être largement utilisé
dans les procédures judiciaires à
condition aussi d'identifier les auteurs
de ces crimes là mais effectivement
comme vous le dites l'ukraine a
malheureusement si je puis dire me
encore en lumière la question des viols
de l'utilisation des viols dans les
conflits et on voit que dans tous les
conflits c'est quelque chose de
récurrent comment on peut faire pour
empêcher justement que les viols en
temps de guerre ne se produise
alors ça c'est une immense question et
je pense que si on avait la réponse on
serait très heureux de la retrouver mais
c'est extrêmement important je crois
déjà il ya une évolution parce qu'on en
parle beaucoup plus et ça c'est
important ça permet aux gens de
comprendre de quoi on pas mais ce qu'il
faut aussi par exemple on parle beaucoup
de formations mais ce qu'il faut c'est
dans les structures militaires il faut
imposer un système de réaction immédiate
par exemple en cas au cas où des soldats
violent donc il faut de la formation et
il faut poursuivre plus parce que je
crois qu'il ya encore une tendance à
penser que les violences sexuelles sont
un peu des crimes de seconde zone et
quand on est un auteur de crime si on a
cette perception qu'ont risquent moins
d'être poursuivie sur ce type de
violence et bien si je pense que ça
encourage à les commettre alors vous
nous disiez justement céline bardet que
c'est violent c'est crimmins désormais
on en parle un peu plus on va voir
peut-être des archives elle derrière
vous parce que ces viols en période de
guerre ont surtout moi tout même parfois
jugée on a les archives de la fin des
années 90 du tribunal pénal pour
l'ex-yougoslavie et ce premier procès
pour violences sexuelles contre des
hommes où on est la justice depuis la
fin des années 90 c'est ce que a
désormais ces procès sont plus fréquents
est-ce que c'est désormais systématique
de trouver justement des preuves pour
montrer qu'il ya toujours des viols en
temps de guerre alors non mais vous
faites bien le souligner parce que moi
j'ai travaillé au tribunal pénal
international pour l'ex yougoslavie qui
a vraiment marqué 1 parce que le tp y il
a poursuivi beaucoup d'affaires pour
viol y compris comme vous le soulignez
de viol contre les hommes parce que ça
concerne aussi les des hommes et des
petits garçons il n'y a pas que les
femmes mais il ya un vrai progrès
maintenant en fait on ne peut pas
détaché non plus la question des
violences sexuelles à celle des crimes
internationaux et on sait que poursuivre
des crimes internationaux bas c'est
compliqué on le voit très bien il ya une
impunité sur la question des conflits
néanmoins oui on en parle beaucoup plus
et donc il ya les enquêteurs et les gens
qui travaillent ils ont beaucoup plus ça
en tête que il n'ya ne serait-ce que 20
ou 25 ans donc ça c'est plutôt bien et
si on regarde la procureur général
d'ukraine par exemple c'est quelque
chose qu'elle a mis en premier elle en
parle énormément donc tout ça ce sont
des progrès c'est ce vers quoi il faut
qu'on se dirige alors ça permettra de
changer des choses on a ces images
d'archivés qui on comprend marqué
l'histoire celle d'un procès justement
on a pu avoir l des coupables et des
victimes qui ont pu être indemnisés puis
il ya aussi des photos ou qui ont marqué
l'image en a peut-être voir celle de la
prison d'abou ghraïb c'était en 2003
lorsqu'on a vu pour la première fois des
militaires américains prendre des photos
humiliantes de prisonniers irakiens ils
avaient été torturés violés est ce que
ces images fortes lorsqu'elle fuites
permettent aussi d'écrire l'histoire et
de de servir dans la formation de ses
militaires alors je pense que
malheureusement ces photos horribles ben
oui elles ont un impact parce qu'elles
ont un impact émotionnel qui est
extrêmement fort mais justement vous
parlez de la prévention je pense que
d'ailleurs c'est valable pour toutes la
question des violences sexuelles un même
en temps de paix c'est qu'il faut qu est
un véritable travail de prise de
conscience de qu'est ce que c'est et
pourquoi on ne peut pas accepter ça en
fait et c'est comme ça qu'on va arriver
à avancer donc c'est important le
plaidoyer c'est important les outils
pédagogiques c'est important parce que
c'est très aussi dans la conscience des
gens comme si c'était quelque chose de
pas très grave ou bon bah ça arrive
voilà non il faut absolument tracé cette
ligne rouge dont parle le docteur denis
mukwege gay et il faut donc qu'on fasse
évoluer nos consciences et ça si c'est
ça c'est extrêmement important à céline
bardet vous nous avez parlé des preuves
vous nous avez parlé des procès vous
nous avez parlé de la formation qu'il
faut faire auprès des armées dernière
question qu'en est il des victimes
comment elles sont accompagnées ensuite
par la suite comment on peut les aider
alors c'est pareil on n'entend plus de
victimes aujourd'hui comme comme vous le
voyez aussi les médias et c'est tant
mieux les médias aussi s'intéressent à
ces questions dont on entend les
victimes donc ça c'est important
maintenant ce qui se passe c'est qu'il
ya celle qu'on entend et puis toutes
celles qu'on n'entend pas qui je pense
représente 95% mais parce qu'on ne sait
pas où elles sont parce qu'on sait pas
comment les accompagner etc on ne sait
pas où les trouver pardon donc nous on a
développé une un site web mobile qui
s'appelle backup et qui permet à toute
victime de s'alerter à travers son
téléphone ou une tablette ou un
ordinateur
est ce qu'il faut faire en fait la
seconde la deuxième chose c'est que on
attend beaucoup de choses des victimes
on leur demande d'apporter plein de
faire c'est de faire ça non il faut à il
faut amener les services à ces victimes
là il faut les identifier et ensuite les
accompagner pour qu'elle puisse se
reconstruire tranquillement
merci beaucoup céline bardet d'avoir
pris le temps de répondre à nos
questions à l'occasion de la journée
internationale pour l'élimination de la
violence sexuelle en temps de conflit
merci merci à vous